CHILDREN IN WAYS THEY WILL LIVE
WITH FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES.
AMERICA'S WAR AGAINST DRUGS
COMING FROM MEXICO IS GOING TO
GET FAR MORE DIFFICULT.
THE PARTY'S NEWLY ELECTED
GOVERNMENT IS MOVING RAPIDLY
TOWARDS A LEGALIZING MARIJUANA.
MEANWHILE, ITS HIGHEST COURT HAS
STRUCK DOWN THE COUNTRY'S LAW
AUTHORIZING THE MILITARY
DEPLOYMENT AGAINST THE DRUG
CARTELS.
MEXICO, THEN, COULD SOON BE FAR
MORE TOLERANT OF DRUGS IN THE
CARTELS.
MEANWHILE, HEROIN BROUGHT IN
OVERWHELMINGLY FROM MEXICO IS
KILLING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS EVERY YEAR.
TUCKER JUST SPOKE WITH AN
ARIZONA SHERIFF ABOUT THE THREAT
OF MEXICAN HEROIN.
HIS COVERAGE.
>> Tucker: OPIOIDS ARE KILLING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
EVERY YEAR.
IT'S AN EPIDEMIC.
IT'S BEING DRIVEN IN PART BY
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, BUT NOT ONLY
BY PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
ALSO HEROIN.
MORE OF IT IS BEING STRUGGLED
INTO THIS COUNTRY THAN EVER
BEFORE AND ALMOST ALL OF THAT
HEROIN IS COMING FROM MEXICO
ACROSS OUR POOREST SOUTHERN
BORDER.
MATT THOMAS IS THE DEPUTY CHIEF
OF POLICE IN ARIZONA, AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS SOMETHING REALLY
DISCUSSED IN WASHINGTON, BUT THE
SCALE OF OPIOID SMUGGLING ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES.
>> WE HAVE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE SINCE 2014.
IT USED TO BE THAT ARIZONA, OUR
SOUTHERN BORDERS, MARIJUANA WAS
THE CASH CROP FOR THE CARTEL,
SPECIFICALLY, THAT IS KIND OF
THE MAIN CARTEL FOR OUR STATE.
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT SHIFT
STARTING IN 2014 WHERE THE
MARIJUANA SMUGGLING STARTED TO
DECLINE AND WE STARTED TO SEE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
SMUGGLING OF HEROIN, FENNEL, AND
METHAMPHETAMINE.
>> Tucker: GIVE US A SENSE,
LARGE AMOUNTS?
IT WOULD DRIVE THE EPIDEMIC THAT
IS KILLING SO MANY AMERICANS?
>> ESPECIALLY, THE DRUG THAT IS
THE DANGER FOR ANYONE WHO IS
USING IT BUT OUR OFFICERS, AS
WELL.
WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL EXPOSURES IN
OUR STATE WHERE OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED AND THEY HAVE
GOTTEN TO HAVE THE NARC INTO
REVERSE THE EFFECTS OF THEY
DON'T DIE OF EXPOSURE.
CITIZENS, THE SAME THING.
THEY OVERDOSED ON AND SO IT IS
MUCH STRONGER THAN HEROIN.
WE HAVE THE HEROIN PROBLEM BUT
NOW WE HAVE THE FENTANYL PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT IS SO DANGEROUS, AND
WE ARE SEEING IT.
IT IS COMING IN THE FORMAT OF
ESSENTIALLY FAKE PILLS.
WHAT THE CARTELS ARE SENDING UP
OUR WHAT ARE BEING SOLD AS OXY,
BUT IT'S FAKE.
IT'S FENTANYL, AND IT'S MORE
POTENT AND MORE DANGEROUS.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE SEEN VIDEO
OF DRUG TUNNELS COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
HOW COMMON ARE THOSE IN YOUR
COUNTY?
>> IN OUR COUNTY, NOT COMMON.
WE ARE OFF THE BOARD ABOUT
70 MILES AND THE COUNTY IS
UNIQUE BEING THAT WE ARE OFF THE
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN D
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN S
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN R
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN T
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN O
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN E
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN B
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN R
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN E
BORDER 70 MILES BUT IT IS OPEN .
THAT IS WHAT KIND OF MAKES US
MORE LIKE A BORDER COUNTY, BUT
FOR THE BORDER COUNTIES IN THE
STATE, PIMA COUNTY, YUMA COUNTY,
VERY COMMON BECAUSE THE CARTEL
IS ESSENTIALLY THE MASTERMINDS
BEHIND THE TUNNELS AND ARIZONA
BEING PRIMARILY RUN BY THE
CARTEL, BURIED, DECEIT TUNNELS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK
WASHINGTON, WHICH IS TRYING TO
RESPOND TO THE OPIOID CRISIS
THAT IS KILLING SO MANY PEOPLE,
DO YOU THINK IN WASHINGTON
LAWMAKERS HAVE A SENSE OF WHERE
THESE DRUGS ARE COMING FROM?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE A SENSE OF
WHERE THEY ARE COMING FROM.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE THEIR
HEADS BURIED PRETTY DEEP IN THE
SAND TO NOT HAVE A SENSE OF THE
AFTER ALL THESE YEARS.
WE KIND OF KNOW WHERE THE SOURCE
IS, BUT I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
A SENSE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF
WHAT'S COMING ACROSS THE BORDER,
HOW EASY IT IS TO GET ACROSS THE
BORDER, AND HOW ADVERSELY IT'S
AFFECTING ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, FROM THE SMALLEST
RURAL COMMUNITY ALL THE WAY TO
YOUR METROPOLITAN AREAS.
IT'S HAVING A VERY NEGATIVE
EFFECT, AND IT'S KIND OF OUR
FAULT ON THE AMERICAN SIDE.
WE ARE THE CONSUMERS, WE HAVE
KIND OF CREATED THIS PROBLEM.
IT'S A DEMAND-DRIVEN THING.